from Forbes cockpit voice recorder on
Alaska Airlines flight 1282 was erased
all right so uh a few days ago there was
an Alaskan Airlines flight from Portland
to Ontario Canada it was no was Ontario
California I think it was I don't know
whatever uh a section of the plane
exploded and was ripped off the plane
I'm being a little hyperbolic it deep it
pre the pressure caused it to blow off
the side of the plane couple cell phones
flew out a a bunch of people's stuff I
guess flew out depressurized cabin the
oxygen Mass come down the initial report
was that a window blew out then you look
at the video I don't know if they have
the video on the Forbes uh uh website
but you look at the video it was
actually apparently these 737 Max 9's
have an optional door Alaska Airline
says we don't want a door there so just
cover it up and the pressure caused to
get ripped off the plane and go flying
and landed in someone's
backyard the cockpit voice recorder on
that plight was erased the question is
why now they'll come on and say oh it's
just an accident is an accident but I
wonder if there's actually some
malfeasance in that right now it's an
argument that the planes are no good
following this report we've got new
information that loose bolts are found
on door plugs on Grounded United
Airlines Boeing 737 max9 jets these door
plugs are areas of the plane they're not
emergency exit they're optional some
they do use some they don't I'm
wondering how much of this is actually
the planes are bad or are we looking at
a diversity higher problem where we have
these pilots who are incapable of doing
their
jobs and so you're getting pilot error
maybe the cabin was pressurized
incorrectly causing the door to blow out
they then yelling in the cockpit what
did you do what did you press oh no I
pressed the wrong button and then they
realize we will get in trouble and be
sued if people find out what we what we
admitted to here so they erase the
blackbox voice recorder so then it's a
oops we have no idea must it just be the
planes are no good Ashley stclair was
tweeting about a flight that landed from
New York New Jersey and it bounced on
the runway hard Landing nearly totaling
the plane I think the plane is disabled
it like the fuselage looks like it was
bent and cracked up and according to as
St Clair or I should say she asked
whether or not this was a diversity hire
who was fired and then rehired even
though they shouldn't have
been we got a pilot shortage flight
cancellations like crazy are these
Airlines hiring in large numbers and are
they hiring for diversity because uh we
know Boeing's all about it take a look
at this Global Equity diversity and
inclusion report I'm wondering if what's
really happening is the infrastructure
failures we're seeing are due to the
fact that all of these companies for the
past decade Plus have been prioritizing
hiring based on ideology instead of
meritocracy yeah and we have that
terrible uh Transportation secretary
right P bu who has no reason to have his
job I mean this system is failing both
privately and in terms of the government
it's it's it's also interesting just as
you know a a consumer uh how much worse
airline travel has gotten since 2020
it's terrible it's terrible flights get
cancel all the time I literally just
this past weekend I had a flight
somewhere and the airline canceled my
flight morning of and rerouted it to a
different city they're like hey like a
city that was like an hour away I was
like they like close enough have a good
time just like send me that's try to fly
switch so so I had a flight from Vegas
to I think it was Dallas to
DC without telling me or asking me they
switched my ticket from a first class to
a coach last minute booking to Colorado
to DC without telling me so we show up
to the airport tickets don't work I'm
confused I'm like trying to scan the
ticket to go through security and then I
look at my email and it's like your
flight has been changed and I was like
wait what so they put me I PID for this
ticket it's expensive and I end up
sitting in the way back in a chair that
like can barely recline wow it's and
it's a trip s to not kidding no they
didn't rebbur you paid for first class
and you had to sit you have like call
the airline to get the reimbursement
it's a pain but the issue was wow none
of my flights were
canceled there was a weather alert in
Dallas and it was delayed but that
didn't mean anything my flight would
would have landed there just fine and
then I could have waited for the delay
and they said it's better if we just put
you on this flight now so you can catch
the Denver to DC and I'm like I'll just
take the delay yeah this it's it's
insane and there's no human beings no
when we showed up to the airport because
we have an early morning flight from DC
to to come back home uh I'm sorry from
Vegas to DC there were no human beings
anywhere when I walked up to a counter I
find I see a United worker I said I I
have a question I know it's the wrong
gate and she goes I'm not on yet and I
was like I'm sorry to bug you I just
maybe you could point me in the right
direction and and then she's like nope I
was like okay dude it's great I think um
a few months ago I had a flight that was
delayed for a solid 8 hours I was like
you could have just like and it was they
do they did that annoying thing where
they delay it 1 hour at a time so you
won't leave right I was like just tell
me how long it's delayed for and I
literally I I sat there for an entire
day I was like I could have got a
different flight or I could have left or
exactly they don't want you to that's
why they lie to you when when a flight
is canceled they've got 100 to 300
people now rushing to the ticket counter
to try and get new flights rather you
just sit there mhm and let their you
know they don't want you causing trouble
yeah and I I don't want to come across
as xenophobic but if I walked in and I
saw two women in the cockpit I would get
off that plane I mean seriously I mean
my my my bigger issue now seriousness is
what if you get on a plane and you see
that 80% are migrants carrying envelopes
and we've got reports Ash Ashley stclair
reported she's in possession of a ticket
that says no name given now I saw the
Tweet I'm not going to sit on a plane
knowing that there's a person who's not
been vetted from security and this is
what's hilarious right the left pushes
for so much documentation everywhere all
the time down to like a covid vaccine
have on their smartphones yeah except
for when it comes to voting except for
when it comes to
migration border illegally during that
time were not asked to get vaccinated
that's exactly right it was a
requirement for legal immigration
exactly so for you as an individual you
are documented every every moment every
inch of your life is totally documented
it's just there's so much paperwork and
red tape associated with everything you
do and then when it comes to illegal
immigrants they go well let's not call
them illegal they're just undocumented
it's like wait don't you guys hate
things being undocumented why are you
okay with this being said they're not
criminals not criminals yeah and that's
rude and Twitter did a commun Twitter
commun not said it's quite literally a
crime to enter the country illegally
there criminals under this section yeah
Nikki Haley is man she's evil she is
she's really evil right because she is
um she's so callous about the interests
of the American people she's okay with
Waging War she literally wanted boots on
the ground in Ukraine so she's
supposedly just this totally hawkish uh
person with respect to foreign policy
and and yet she all of a sudden just has
a bleeding heart when it comes to
migration you kidding me well you know
what that reminds me of like have you
seen where their celebrities now are
writing their names on the bombs that
are being used in Gaza no yeah and like
supposedly yeah some Israeli porn stars
or whatever got in trouble cuz they let
it star you know uh right on one of the
bombs supposedly but I always think
that's very you know morbid very mob to
write your name on a bomb and you know
this is I don't care what side you're on
but that's kind of like where we're at
of the the weirdness of this all I think
that's and you know I look at everything
we're seeing with
um just the the the the the the the
extreme political actions that are
happening I mean the border is just is
gone mhm Mexico wanting to uh uh well
the Border gone for them cuz Tim you and
I need a passport to leave I can't leave
the country without a passport so The
Border's closed for you and I but
they're bringing people in and I just
look at all this and I'm how do we get
through this election cycle there I I
don't I don't know how come November
2024 November 6th it's going to be
November 5th we get election day does
anyone really believe that on November 6
they're going to be like and that's it
the winner of the election is and have a
name
no of course they won't be like that I
mean the thing is this is going to be
hardfought all the way and we have known
this for a long time when when Trump was
elected in 2016 you would remember do
you remember all the pictures from
flights of like women in their pink hats
going to the rally like there has been
this test of like if you're the right
side you're allowed to protest but if
you're the wrong side you're not allowed
to do
anything that's been there for a long
time but our tension and our anger and
the the distrust of the other side is
more heightened than ever so I think
November 6th will be a really chaotic
day and it will lead into a very chaotic
2025 that's understatement of the year I
think 20125 is going to be crazy this
the next election cyle be 24 is going to
be like one of no 2025 might be super
chill you you think after it's all done
after everything's burn down sitting
there with like we'll be wearing potato
sacks sitting outside playing with
chickens okay what's the new Obama movie
on Netflix uh uh you know talking about
how they're going to be a Cyber attack I
think there is going to be a Cyber
attack this year and you know what's
going to be the scary part we keep on
seeing all this about airplanes that's
what really gets messed up if the
internet goes down you know all of a
sudden planes are going to start
crashing and then you're really going to
be like I think it's possible I possible
it's not that PL ples AR going to crash
not going to fly when the when the
system what's a surge where you can turn
off computers I know I can't think of
the ter yes what if they use that and
all of a sudden air planes in the air it
would be you're not going to EMP the
whole planet yeah but I'm just talking
about a small part of it I mean forget
the whole planet if the internet goes
out planes will emergency land and then
be unable to take off they're going to
say we can't air traffic control
properly our data streams are shut shut
down it's an emergency and it's a very
effective way to temporarily control uh
flow of communication imagine what would
happen for every we got 45,000 people
they're watching right now what if the
internet went down what would you watch
are you going are you really going to
turn on CNN
MSNBC there's no internet but TV still
works and they say you know turn on the
radio turn on the TV and now you're
getting the approved government
narrative well I think in this day and
age the TV and that stuff would go off
with the internet too you think they
would still be able to broadcast
absolutely yep they would just should be
using anal analog whatever that yeah
yeah they do uh they do um yeah I guess
you are right it's still digital air
it's it's digital now so you get
multiple data streams over the airwaves
but they can still send through just you
can buy TV turn it on and you can get
the uh the standard you know digital
channels and what what Hannah said
earlier I think that's the reason why so
many Boomers have cogn Hannah CLA what
did I say yeah no I'm just saying the
reason why these forgot half my name but
sorry I always just say Hannah Hannah
CLA what I'm saying is uh these rors
they have such bad cognitive dissonance
because they didn't have as many outlets
like we had they didn't have the
internet to tell them the truth about
the government that these people know
the government lies to them but they
still trust the government for some
reason we've lost all government trust
because we have the internet we know
what the hell is going on and they got
to take that away yeah and we can look
up the Tuskegee civilist we can look up
all this crazy stuff that you know is
really not the moonlanding right hey
that's what I learned I'm just saying
because of the internet that's what's
probably did you the biggest thorn in
the government side did you see the
report I don't know enough about it but
I saw I passively saw so someone correct
me if I'm from China that said the
mooning fake no they said that our
current nuclear technicians don't know
how to operate them fully because the
people who actually ran and maintained
them have retired long since retired and
the people who who who've inherited the
these jobs never had actual reason to so
it's like Homer literally like Homer
that's 30% of our infrastructure and so
when you say how did we lose technology
for the moon landing the exact same
reason why they're saying our current
technicians don't know how to operate
our nuclear weapons well don't even get
me started that's apples in orig just I
do agree with that but uh yeah I mean I
don't even want to get started on the
moon landing but yeah I'm not surprised
that these idiots can't figure out how
like look at our buildings look at all
the postmodernism all of our
architecture the bridge that collapsed
in Florida was that recently I didn't no
this is like oh yeah in Miami you're
talking about The Pedestrian Bridge
pedestrian bridge yeah and it killed
like two students six people yeah I I it
could be updated since then I don't know
but uh there were memes going around
saying a female lead construction
company had built it and then the fact
Checkers came out and said did an all
female lead all female Construction
Company build it see what happens is
people pointed out that this company was
promoting diversity they were promoting
female construction workers do they're
doing ads saying women are strong they
did all this but only a small portion of
the women in people in management were
women and so it was run it was run on by
a bunch of guys but they kept bragging
about the women who were in charged so
when people came out and said that it
was a female Le company in order to try
and quote unquote debunk it or I guess
you call it a faux buunk it's not a real
debunking the media changed female Le to
all female well of course the company
was all female and they say it's owned
by a man therefore they're lying thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net